depuis la nuit des temps
la lune fascine les hommes qui lui
confère volontiers une incidence sur les
événements terrestres cette nuit avait
lieu la super lune des fleurs un
évènement astronomique rares et peu
connu la super lune c'est lorsque la
lune est proche de la terre et qu'elle
apparaît plus grosse et donc elle est
également un petit peu plus lumineuse
on raconte aussi que cette super lune
comme les saints de glace indiquerez la
fin des gelées super le dépasser tout
est passé on peut
l'aïe a aucun problème on peut faire ce
qu'on veut ça va pas gelé depuis
toujours
marcel jardine en fonction des cycles de
la lune en s'aidant de ce petit manuel
la lune montante c'est pour les légumes
au dessus de la terre descendante c'est
les légumes
arras et c'est à dire les pommes de
terre jean pierre lui n'a jamais entendu
parler de cette super lune
même s'il suit parfois le calendrier
lunaire pour ses plantations
je reporte différence et c'est cher je
sème avec la lune ou pas donc ça dépend
comment je suis l'une est alors sur ce
point que dit la science la lune at elle
réellement une incidence sur les plantes
scientifiquement non par contre sur la
mentalité des gens oui c'est à dire qu'à
partir du moment où vous êtes convaincus
que la lune peut avoir une influence
vous allez à agir en conséquence et vous
allez voir un comportement qui peut
rendre des résultats qui soit positif
puisque vous à l'éliminer d'autres
problèmes mais c'est pas la lune qui est
en cause c'est la coutume qu'il est quoi
qu'il en soit la super lune étaient
visibles dans notre pays cette nuit à 3
heures 49
elle pouvait apparaître jusqu'à 14% plus
grosse et 30% plus lumineuse que
lorsqu'elle est à son point le plus
éloigné